MANDY WAITE: So for GAE
Java there is detailed
documentation for low-level
data store API.
However, fewer, and incomplete
documentation, for how to map
entity relationships
with JDO JPA.
DataNucleus is detailed, however
no easy way to tell if
GAE supports a feature.
So, there's a question
there somewhere.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, so the
question is really I think
around getting to the full
details and capabilities of
JDO and JPA on App Engine.
Maybe I should put this a
little bit in context.
When we launched the Java
runtime on App Engine, we
looked at the active frameworks
and abstractions
that people were using.
JDO and JPA were very popular.
And so we did a lot of work to
make sure that those were
properly supported
in App Engine.
We also felt like users really
benefited from SQL-like
language, and so we launched GQL
as a way of accessing the
data store.
And what we found over time,
actually, is that developers,
after a little while, feel
much more productive when
they're working much closer with
the low-level APIs of App
Engine, or some abstraction
that sits on top of those
low-level APIs.
So in the case of Python,
we had the
low-level Python data store.
We've now iterated on that and
we have NDB, the new database
one, which is sort of the way
that we wish we had written it
the first time with Memcache
built in, and just usability
is a lot better.
On the Java side, we've actually
had the community
step up and produce an ORM
framework called Objectify.
And there's others out there.
There's a developer in
Japan who created
something called Slim3.
It's another abstraction
layer for Java.
And they do a really good job of
sort of abstracting the way
of the data store a little bit,
but still staying very
close to the native performance
characteristics,
doing things kind of
the right way.
Objectify, I know, also
has Memcache built in.
And it just lets you
work with POJOs, so
Plain Old Java Objects.
So you have a Java object with a
bunch of properties, getters
and setters.
You can just take that object
and you push it in the data
store, get it right back out.
And that really feels a lot more
natural working in App
Engine than the JDO and JPA.
And so the way to kind of look
at those technologies right
now is, if you're a big JDO and
JPA fan, or you just use
those in your environment, and
you'd like to, please continue
to use them.
They're there for you.
But if you're kind of new to App
Engine, or you're at all
unfamiliar about JDO and JPA,
by all means use either the
low-level APIs, or something
like Objectify in Java,
because you'll just have a
much better experience.
And those were written from the
ground up for App Engine.
Whereas JDO and JPA were
written in a world
where SQL was king.
And it's a little bit
of an unnatural fit.
We got that square peg into the
round hole, but we had to
use a hammer a little bit, and
so the corners are a little
bit rounded off.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
I come from a Java EE
background, so I used to have
a very big hammer.